ich habe Wahnsinn Wahnsinn sind viele Pärchen
hier heute auch sehe ich ne wie wir sind viele
verheiratet man Handtuch wäre es verheiratet
wir verheiratet das ist oh ja sind auch ein paar
Dinge schon klar 50% von ihnen werden geschieden
ist auch mal schön sowas machen jetzt noch
und dann das können vielleicht demnächst
sehr teuer für Sie sein es ist schon eher ich
meine würden Sie ein Auto einsteigen was jedes
zweite explodieren auch nicht machen also ich
bin auch verheiratet ich habe das also ich habe
auch diesen Schwur in also was heißt ich also
ich habe nur gesagt und der Mann vor mir hat
geschworen und dich darüber gut sein ja aber ähm
ich habe auch dieses in guten wie in schlechten
wir werden ja auch immer älter ich
meine der Tod das ist verdammt weit weg
zeitlich gesehen ist das also das sieht man nicht
so weit weg ist das ist so ein das ist ja für
immer also da hatten die das im Mittelalter ja
vielleicht ja da sind Sie ja schneller gestorben
verstehen sie nein da sind sie mit Mitte 30 waren
sie tot also wenn sie mit 32 geheiratet haben
ja also die drei ja da brauchst du dich auch nicht
auseinander zu leben weil das ist ein bisschen
raus also der ja man kann schon sagen früher
wenn man glücklicher weil man halt den Ausstieg
aber jetzt oh
und bei mir im Freundeskreis fängt das jetzt auch
so an ne da ist sie sie die zweite Runde wird da
eingeläutet ne die lassen die sind immer
noch verliebt aber halt in der andere und
was mich dann notiert das ist dieses dieses
Mitleids Gehäuse ne dieses oder dann immer
ja ich habe sie auch schon am Anfang gemacht so
richtig passt und die nicht die wollte ja immer
ein Arzt ne solche Sprüche kommen dann immer und
das ist diese diese Hobby Psychologie ist Globuli
wissen das geht mir auf den Sack das mag ich nicht
nee nein nein ich gehe zum Beispiel ich sage immer
was ich sage also wenn ich sehe da im Löffel
Freundeskreis irgendwas falsch und sage ich was
ich sag was auch wenn ich sage dann was also das
nein nein ich bringe das mal auf den Tisch damit
ich damit die das schon mal so erörtern können
ja ich sage manchmal Sachen die nicht stimmen
verstehe ich sag dann so also zu meinem Freund
Jochen seid ja du ich habe gestern auch Susanne
mit dem anderen Typen gesehen das sage ich dann
einfach na ja nein da muss sie sich auch einfach
mal so rechtfertigen verstehen und dann ähm
und Krisen ja auch die Beziehung oder was Gutes
so muss man das sehen und dann kann er also
Sebastian Blödsinn erzählt dann kommt er das
stimmt ja gar nicht oder mein Fehler ist ja nicht
schlimm und aber ich mache es auch aktiv also ich
mache so wenn wir zum Beispiel so auf einer Party
sind dann sage ich auch gerne bei verheirateten
Frauen nee die Single und dann erzähle ich das
anderen Männern nach dem Motto dass sie die auch
mal so anbaggern richtig an weil das auch mal so
eine Frau unter Beschuss verstehen zu verstehen
also und dann sage ich mal guck mal guck mal
guck mal was er da macht ne das ist wichtig ja
manchmal bestelle ich auch gerne Stripper zu den
nach Hause wenn ich weiß wann der Mann ungefähr
nach Hause kommt bestellt weißt du das kurz bevor
der nach Hause kommt der macht die Tür auf steht
und halt nach der Typ dann da und dann musst du
dann aber erstmal erklären ne also ist gut für
die Beziehung ne und wenn das nicht funktioniert
Frauen das mache ich ja das dann verabrede ich
mich ja dann gehen Kaffee trinken oder treffen uns
in der Lobby von unserem Hotel und dann reden wir
erstmal gut wie gestern dann viel über ihn aber
dann reden wir und dann habe ich irgendwann so
aus Versehen so ein Hotelzimmer so haha guck
mal ein Hotelzimmer Schlüssel dass man damit
wohl machen kann sage ich dann immer so und wenn
wir da in der Kiste dran weil ich auch du [__]
weißt du und das sage ich sofort mein Freund
das heißt weißt du eigentlich was du dafür eine
Drechsel das ist ja egal ja gut der redet jetzt
nicht mehr mit mir das Blöde war sie kam dann auf
mich zu wollte bei mir einziehen aber auch gesagt
Mädchen du darfst doch noch vom Vorgänger ja okay
okay das war jetzt nein das war jetzt ich aber
das ist doch kein Argument das muss man auch mal
Beziehungen sind so wichtig halten
Sie dran fest dargestellt [Applaus]
ach so abonnieren Sie diesen Kanal
dann wird es lustig ihr Puffer